Hey guys.
Thanks so much for checking out this special spooky episode of odd man out for
Halloween.
And a big thank you to our sponsor.
Manscaped and I think it's pretty appropriate because the new wee
Wacker is like magic.
It's basically like a magic wand that you put up your nose and then like all
your nose hair managed because it is that powerful.
You can get it as part and the new performance package,
which includes all the tools you love or the boil waste, grooming and hygiene.
You need get 20% off plus free shipping with promo code Jubilee at
manscaped that.
Thank you to manscape for keeping our pubes trimmed and nose free of weeds.
20 episodes, happy Halloween,
only person. Who's going to be entertained by that though. What was your,
it was a two-part.
Yo, no way, Bonnie. That's exactly the card. I hope.
I would say the two.
We brought together seven magicians.
I'm a magician. I'm a magician. I am a magician and I'm a magician.
I'm a magician. Hollywood's favorite.
I am a magician.
One is a liar. If the group discovers who the liar is, they'll win a cash prize.
If the liar survives, they win the cash prize. This is odd man out.
You have much of a game plan at all. You're a real performing magician.
There's things that just experiences that you just would have to have for
yourself. So there's no way you could fake it.
I think the person who was not a magician, it's probably going to say the most
[inaudible] I'm a Spanish, but I am based in London.
I don't know if they're going to think I'm the mom,
just because the fact that I'm a girl,
I'm just excited to see these other magicians and talk about magic.
This is what I do every single day. So it shouldn't be a lot of fun.
This is our trick round.
Everyone will get three minutes to perform a trick for the group.
Let's begin with member one.
First off I'm magic. What's up. Let's try something here. Um, I got a bunch of,
a bunch of different random cards. Now these are all Halloween themes.
We've got things like candy, go score. Mummy, pumpkin, clown, goblin,
gravestone. Just to name some. Um, now you can have any one of these.
I want it to be a completely fair choice. So whichever one that you want, uh,
I'm going to go through and you can name one. Whichever one.
It seems like it already, just by the performance.
You want to go with skull and see, where was that?
I'm going to give you one chance.
Do you want to change your mind or do you want to keep it skull?
You like knows how to do.
Like video magic. Keep it skull. You want.
To keep it? Okay. Interesting. I'm going to leave it right here. Uh,
hopefully we can see that the entire time. Now look, I'm going to try something.
Um, you could have had anyone that was completely fair.
I'm going to show you that the backs of these ones,
all of these cars are completely blank on the back of them. But, uh,
but last night I had a vision. Okay. I had a vision. In fact,
I was so confident that you're going to keep it skull,
that I actually took a marker and I wrote a big black X on back of one
card. I love it.
And that is your selection skull, right? Yeah. I love that's my trick.
I almost thought I almost thought goblin.
I know you could have changed your mind,
but moving it out of it and not have an awkward number two.
How you doing? Okay. It's same.
I was thinking to do because a lot of people aren't doing cut tricks,
but I mean, it's pretty cool, right? Just a little bit with the iPhone.
Okay. Now let's, let's say, um, a little bit with a coin. Let me say,
let me show you something cool. All right.
So she's got like magic props.
The guest magicians knows the rising card, but this is,
I call it the rising cone, because watch, when I shake my hand,
you'll see how, Oh, that's really good.
I watch the next one. I like,
even if I take a little bit more slowly to shams all the way to the top,
bam. Right?
That was dope. I get some, I get some confetti. Let's go. Number three.
Let's go to Ali.
Hi. So I'm going to show you this magic trick and you see that all the courage
addiction. Oh, look at that spread. He's legit.
So what I'm going to try to do is I want to actually try to find the four ACEs.
The first one, if I give it a cut and I give it two more cuts,
I think the first one happens to be Friday six from the top so I can try to get
it right. The second one,
I think probably it's only five from the top. So we'll try and do it.
I'll try and do something a little different.
I just try and check the deck happened to pop up as the next day
I get the deck voted kit out. This is so good. Another cut.
I should be able to find the next day.
So can you see that the deck of chef was here? Right? I'll get that one fat bowl
and I'll take the deck. And one in 52 chance.
I'll use my phone just to pull at one time. That happened to be the last days.
Okay. Awesome. Thank you. Number three.
I'm glad I don't have to follow up that kid.
The future of magic is in good hands.
I'm going to switch it up for the rest of the order. What student numbers? Six.
Um, okay, so we've got a deck of cards, um, and I just want you to free select,
to say stop whenever. Right? So, um,
I'm looking away, right? We're going to pick two cards.
Here's this and then this card as well. Okay.
You see this? Yeah. Okay. So, um,
you've got this two cards in your head. I'm going to try to remember, uh,
figure out what they are. So, um, bold move.
Okay. All right. Was one of
the ACE of spades. It was. Okay.
So we're going to find the other card. I know you're probably not that, that,
uh, amazed because this is zoom and everything and nothing's amusing over zoom,
but, uh, we're going to try to do this. So if you can see,
I'm drawing it to be like 3d kind of thing. Right.
And so it looks like a 3d card box. Right. And you'll see,
it's kind of cool because if I take this card box, right.
And I just kind of shake it like this, it looks as though
out of the card box and, uh,
that is the four diamonds. Okay, cool. Yeah.
All right. Number six. Had a great trick.
Oh, for that either. Let's go. Number five.
Am I allowed to say my name? I get paranoid. Yes. Yeah. You can figure it out.
Okay. Hi. Okay. I'm Zach mirrors. I would like to show you something, Bonnie,
uh, in theater class,
have you seen the illusion where someone takes a
sword and they put it through a person's body and on this way it looks
like, you know, but this way it isn't seems legit.
I want to try something. All right. I've got this, um,
a knife right over here. I know danger. And I've got a,
uh, I've got a deck of cards. So check it out.
The knife goes all the way through the deck of cards, just like so,
but what's interesting is, is he stabbing a really nice deck by let go.
It's kind of still there, but if I show you,
it actually is all the way through the deck of cards. Pretty interesting.
But there are no cards inside at all. Let's see if I take this out.
Can I show you what's inside? It is a solid block.
I know that this killer half-inch piece,
Steve.
Kind of gutsy for him to do a trick like that.
Yes. Where did he go?
He's a magician that guys, he trusts me. Number seven.
Are you ready? My name is Yvonne. I'm going to show you something really cool.
Bonnie, have you ever had your mind read before? I don't think so. All right.
Great. This is kind of like that, but a little bit different.
I used to do Rubik's cubes growing up as a kid. And once I became a magician,
it actually became a lot easier to solve the Rubik's cube,
but I'm going to try something with you, right through zoom.
Are you ready for that? I have another cue here.
They say there are six sides to the cube.
I'm going to ask you to name the side, front back left. Right?
Top bottom. And add you name a side. I will turn that side. Front back,
left top bottom. It is up to you. Go, go for it.
You'll go right bottom, bottom. Let's go. Keep going.
Keep going a couple more top, uh, top. Here we go.
Top keeping going up left front three more,
three more back. That would be back. Two more,
two more left. That would be left. And one more,
one more bottom and bottom. Now you have no idea what you just did here,
but in a way you actually solved this release. Cute.
Let me show you. You'll notice. There's a bag right here inside this bag.
There is actually another cue, but I want you to look closely.
I want you to see this. Can you see that?
That's actually a perfect match right there now just on one side,
but check it out. That is two sides. A perfect match. Not just two sides.
That would be three sides of perfect match. That would be four.
So every single side, five sides, six sides of the cube.
Perfect. A person that is, that is fantastic.
Grooves tubes are really popular right now. Number seven is also a magician.
All right. And last but not least number four.
My name is Jeff Black. Jeff Black sounds like a magician.
And today I brought a deck of cards, but this one's a little bit strange.
It's actually a blank deck of cards. You ever seen a blank deck of cards,
Bonnie. Okay. First time for everything.
We're going to try and do magic with this,
but first I want you to think of any card. Don't even say it.
Just think of it in your mind. Do you have one? Yeah. Okay.
So I'm going to reach through the camera right into your mind.
And I'm going to pull out the one card that you're thinking of.
And I think this is a great choice. I think in fact, I'm going to commit,
this is the card right here. I would like this to stay in the frame.
Okay. Um, so for the first time I'm committed,
would you go ahead and just say it out loud? What was your card?
Here's a two-part yo, no way, Bonnie.
That's exactly the card I hoped you would say now I don't want to brag,
but this really is the two of hearts.
And that's the challenge of a blank deck. Obviously,
if it was printed out would have been it. But thank you for humoring me.
In fact, let's use your magic to overcome that challenge.
So if you had a magic word, what would it be? If it could be anything,
what would it be? Sparkle. Sparkle. Okay.
We're going to do this with one hand. Okay.
Can you still see the blank card if I hold it like one, two,
three sparkle
and it prints one random card. Now of course, I know that isn't your card,
but you did more than that. Bonnie, you printed two cards. Oh,
you didn't stop there though.
You printed every single card in the
deck. Ooh. In fact,
I know it's already very impressive. Right. But the best isn't that?
Not that you've printed every card in my hand, but honestly,
the best part is you printed the one.
I wasn't even touching the one that you merely thought of.
The two of.
Dude. Yes. It's so good. I love that.
I think I might get kicked out because everybody else did really good.
And especially doing it virtual. Let me say that was fantasy.
I mean, I'm just barely safe that I did my truck. Right?
Cause it was pretty difficult.
The youngest nutrition,
some of the best handling and presentation I've seen with someone his age. So.
Pieces of car flicks and slight of hand things that take a lot of things.
The ones who did the arm trick seemed a bit more nervous than a lot of the other
people, which is sign number one to me,
which you might not be a magician because I forget his name. I'm sorry.
I'm terrible with names, but.
The arm guy over one was a great performer. I didn't sense any nerves,
but this trick in my opinion was easiest to perform. Even if he's strict,
he was very great. If.
I'm going to go to number six, I am going to vote for the short guy,
the guy that shored the knife through the cut. I can't remember, sir. I am like,
I have bad memory. I'm pretty suspicious of him.
Cause he could just pull that off.
After about a minute of handling what he had voting for number six,
it seemed like they had a lot of nerves around performing that trick as if it
was brand new.
I'm going to vote for knife guy. That's the only trick that's like.
Doesn't use carts and isn't immediately obvious what his skill level is.
I don't know. They're I think they're all magicians,
but I have to vote for someone. The guy that did the arm thing.
The votes are in the person eliminated this round
is number six.
Thank you. Number six.
Doing it over. Zoom is pretty tough. It was in person.
I think I would have stood a pretty good chance.
I should have just had like a deck of cards, like stacked up behind me.
Like who does that? You know what I mean? Like, look at this. Look at,
look at this, look at this. You know, I should have put this up there.
We'll look at it.
What's up guys. This is so fun. Nice performance. Hey, Hey
Ali. You're amazing. You're so good buddy.
Never seen that guys. Where are you based? I'm from Dallas, Texas.
So I say y'all a lot. So go Cowboys, Philadelphia,
PA homie rays on the playgrounds where I spend most of my days. Oh LA. Oh,
right near, um, the what's that place in LA where they do that.
You went to the magic.
Who to you see? Who is your favorite magician there?
David Regal like was on.
Did he do this trick right here? Now he invented like, Whoa,
we're still up. We're still on. YouTube is YouTube. No, no, no. Uh,
no methods or the technical. I get nervous about that.
How many years have you guys done magic for the team? Yeah. Eight.
I mean, whenever I saw that Blaine special when I was a kid.
So that was the one for me too.
Like an hour now, a year and a half. Probably a year and a half.
You're insane for a year and a half. Number three.
Hey Ali. Okay buddy. You remember me? Okay.
When you grow older and then if you need someone to work for you,
you let me absolutely. I know you've got an amazing start conventions.
You guys have been to magic, magic live. I have not. First time. Last year.
It was amazing.
From Europe is black bull. It's expensive to go all the way to.
Do. I want to go to a black hole. Yeah. I want to go to Blackpool as well.
That's one, that's one of my list. I've been the magic Fest.
Number one. Who's your favorite magician or what's your favorite magic book?
Um, my favorite magician is I got to give it to David Blaine. I know.
It's kind of like, like everybody's a lot of people's favorite magician,
but yeah, David blades,
my favorite magician favorite magic book would be probably 13, 13.
I'm pretty in the new 13 steps. Steps to, yeah.
Mentalism is probably my favorite classic. Why would they be blamed?
I like David Blaine because I feel like he really brought attention to,
uh, to the, to the whole street magic thing. And I, and he,
he was a really one who went out and recorded it and had that special history,
super special.
And I think that was probably what inspired me to kind of go do something.
Okay. We have five seconds.
Thanks Ali. Sorry man. Yes. Kind of singled me out and was like, Hey,
what's your favorite magic book? And I was like, okay.
I love talking about magic. I love me. I've never met these. Medallia's awesome.
I really like Ali a lot.
I think we got rid of them all. We'll have to get rid of someone. Yeah. So yes.
I'll say number one.
Yeah. My vote is going to be number two. I'm sorry. Number two. I,
no, wait. That's not right.
Number one. His favorite magician is David Blaine.
That is a totally legitimate choice to have for a favorite magician.
It's just rather pub.
I told you at the beginning, no one famous magician.
The magician knew just like just the most popular magician.
Everyone has their own unique one. I think there's something up with him.
I'm going to dude, Jeff Black, just because I have to vote,
but I still think he's a magician, but like his math mustache too.
But number one, smelling kind of mold, mold patrol.
I definitely feel like I'm about to get voted out for some reason.
The person eliminated this round is
number one. Sorry. Number one,
guys. That hurt.
Nah, it's all good.
I should have came in with a more powerful trick to kind of show off, you know,
my, my card skills and number two saying David Blaine was my favorite magician.
Because even though that is true, David blades, the most well-known magician,
I could see why they would think that I am not a magician because that's my
answer. As weird as that is.
Up. If you wish to continue the game or thumb down,
if you think you caught them all and you went to end for the game three, two,
one go.
Yeah.
All right. So majority rules.
If the light behind me turns green,
you guys have voted them all out and you have one.
If the light behind me turns red,
the mall is still in the game and you have lost.
[Inaudible].
Can I please have my Mo my fake magician raise his hand
one, two.
Oh, it rough guys. I was watching,
I was watching the performances go and I'm like, Oh my God,
why did I pick a cartridge? Oh man. That is so fun.
You did it so well. How long did you work on that for? Well, okay.
So I have like some amateur magic background, but I don't,
I've never done it professionally.
So I grew up super shy and magic was a way of kind of being able to walk up to
random strangers and just show them something a moment. And the energy,
when I first saw magic, when I was a kid was kind of the reaction,
the energy I wanted to have around me in my job or
art forms. I used to think that I needed to put messages in my tricks.
And I realized that just bringing out the inner child is enough.
It's just all about the audience.
And it's made them forget about the real world for a little like five
seconds. I'm just happy. No, that was awesome.
Number three. How old are you, dude? They just turned nine, like on Wednesday.
Oh, you're awesome, dude. You got a card flips and everything already.
Amazing birthday man. Once, uh, COVID is over.
I met out reunion at black pool. Let's do it. Hey, we're all family.
We're all family. Even number six. I will ask my mom. I will ask my mom.